Narrator:
For over a decade,
"Shark Tank" has been at
the forefront of innovation...
And now I'm here, man.
For me, this is
the American dream already.
I think that watching
"Shark Tank" as a kid
helped me be standing
in front of you all today.
Narrator:
...showcasing America's
most ingenious products
and trendsetting ideas.
There you go.
[ Chuckles ]
Whoo‐hoo!
And tonight, CEO of RSE Ventures
and vice chairman
of the Miami Dolphins
Matt Higgins
returns to the Tank.
I understand this market.
I have the ability
to talk to the customer
that you're targeting.
Just when you think
you've seen it all...
Whoo!
...there's always something new
coming in the Tank.
Which of these companies
will be the next big idea?
Let's get started!
The future starts now.
[ Electricity crackling ]
♪♪
First in the Tank
is a product that brings
all the conveniences of your
kitchen to the great outdoors.
♪♪
Taylor: Hi, Sharks.
I'm Taylor.
I'm Ron.
My name is Kobe,
and we're from
Grand Junction, Colorado.
And we are seeking $250,000
for 10% of our company
that will revolutionize
the outdoors forever.
Have you ever
unpacked your campsite
and realized you forgot
something important,
like salt, oil,
or a spatula?
Does your picnic table
look like this?
♪♪
[ Chuckles ]
Together:
Well, ours did.
Interpreter: We were so sick
of disorganized camping.
It was frustrating.
So, we came up
with this idea
that there has to be
a better way,
which is why we created
Tailgate N Go.
Tailgate N Go is a portable,
modular outdoor kitchen
and dry box
that you can take anywhere ‐‐
camping, fishing, tailgating,
any outdoor adventure.
It starts
in this simple box.
♪♪
Most of our attachments
fit inside the box.
♪♪
The modular design
enables you
to put the attachments in
any 10 locations around the box.
♪♪
This patented
modular design
enables 360 degrees
of function and versatility.
Oh, wow.
Wow.
It has everything you need
from your kitchen at home,
even sinks.
[ Water runs ]
[ Chuckles ]
Nice.
Interpreter: Tailgate N Go
is a one‐of‐a‐kind product.
There's nothing like it
in the marketplace.
But in order to be a success,
we need your help
to reach our full potential.
So, Sharks, let's all
think outside the box
and start
an outdoor revolution.
[ Chuckles ]
Good job.
Good job, guys.
Really cool.
How'd you come
to invent this?
We went camping.
We're sitting there,
searching for a spatula
for 30 minutes.
We're arguing,
so we finally just said,
"Hey, let's go home
and invent this."
So, we get home,
and just all the ingenuity
just came
really between the three of us
of, "What do you need in
necessity in your kitchen?"
How long ago
was this?
One year.
So, this has only been
on the market recently?
Year and a half.
Wow.
How much does
this go for, retail?
♪♪
Interpreter: Well,
there's three different models.
The first model
is the full‐sized model,
and it costs about $1,500.
Ooh.
Whoa.
Our second model
is the Overlander,
and it sells
for around $1,400.
Ooh.
And we have a brand‐new model,
and it's about $1,000.
How many have you sold?
We have sold
over a hundred boxes.
We've only gone
to six trade shows.
What does it cost you
to make?
So, for our full‐size model ‐‐
$748 to manufacture.
Our second model, it costs about
$728 to manufacture.
And our River Box costs $500
to manufacture.
And where
do you make these?
Everything we make
is in Colorado right now.
Greiner:
So, two questions.
Taylor: Okay.
One ‐‐
what does it weigh?
75 pounds on the large box,
55 on the small box.
Okay.
And then we have
new products coming where,
when they're in plastic,
they're gonna be much lighter.
So, what does it cost
to ship that, then?
Around $120, $150.
You have any patents?
We have two patents.
They're both provisional
utility patents ‐‐
on the railing here,
how we can put everything
in the slots, on aluminum,
and what's most important ‐‐
roto‐mold plastic.
Guys,
these aren't cheap to build,
particularly when
you're starting
and making mistakes
and iterating.
How much money
have you invested?
Have you raised
any outside capital?
No.
So, what we did ‐‐
we took our savings.
I got $250,000 invested
in this entire process.
We're real tight
with the money...
Good.
...and one of the reasons
we're here
is because we don't want
to make a mistake
at the first product.
Why is this business worth
$2 1/2 million?
You know I have to ask
that question...
Yes.
Yes, you do.
...and I'm doing it
in the nicest way.
If I don't like the answer,
then things get ugly.
With the patents
that we have,
there's no other product
like this,
and I feel
we have this window
to take over
the whole outdoor.
I don't think
I like that answer enough.
We need to scale this puppy,
and we need to scale it fast.
And what is the $250,000
gonna be used for?
Inventory.
Just product.
Before, you said
you could bring the cost down
by going to plastic,
including the entry‐level unit
of $1,000?
So, you're bringing that down
to what price point?
Well, yeah, our cost on that
is around $748.
We can bring that down
in the $300, $200 range.
So, you're retailing it
for $750 or something?
If we scale.
To scale.
If we scale
and source.
We're completely in Colorado
right now,
so we can get
those prices down...
even in America,
I'm sure.
But, you know, being in
Colorado's not a bad thing,
but first,
let me say this ‐‐
you know,
there's an old saying ‐‐
"Necessity is
the mother of invention."
Ron: Yes.
You guys
had a problem,
you came up
with a solution,
you turned it
into a business,
you saved your money
to be able to do it yourself
without
any outside help.
Right.
You are
the American dream.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Cuban: I mean,
that's incredible.
That's the good news.
[ Chuckling ] Yeah.
The bad news is,
I don't glamp.
It's just
not a fit for me.
Ron: Right.
So, for those reasons,
I'm out,
but congratulations,
guys.
It's just awesome,
awesome, awesome
what
you've accomplished.
♪♪
You know, I don't know very much
at all about tailgating.
I always like to kind of know
what's the landscape
before I invest
in something
that's so at
the beginning stages.
And so, for those reasons,
I'm out.
♪♪
In the last six months,
we've tripled our sales.
We haven't even
gotten out there yet.
O'Leary: You know,
I look at this and say
the proof is in the fact
people bought it,
but you're not worth
$2.5 million,
so that was a big ask.
I love the patent stuff
and all of that.
Right.
This is
a cash‐flow business.
In other words,
it sucks up cash
'cause you build inventory.
So, here's an idea,
just throwing it out there ‐‐
this kind of fits
in my Chef Wonderful world,
although I hate camping.
If I don't have a mint
on my pillow,
I don't sleep there.
[ Chuckles ]
That's how it works.
You need
a line of credit.
Here's an idea,
if you consider it ‐‐
I'll give you the $250,000
line of credit,
I want
a 10% interest on it,
I want the 10% equity
if somebody buys you out,
and I want $100 royalty
per unit
against the $250,000.
Higgins: Ooh.
John: Whoa!
Greiner: Alright.
There goes your margin.
Hey, I don't hear
any other offers.
Kevin didn't give you
the fine print.
The royalty is forever.
They know that.
Guys, I could blow this up
so big on social.
I'm just worried
you can't do the orders.
I mean,
I got millions of followers.
Well, that's why
we need Sharks ‐‐ to scale it.
Higgins:
So, just to jump in ‐‐
I understand
this market.
I have the ability
to talk to the customer
that you're targeting
because I'm vice chairman
of Miami Dolphins,
I spend my Sundays
at NFL games,
we have the largest
privately owned
soccer tournament
in the world,
and I know how to talk
to the sports customer
that you're looking
to go after.
What concerns me is that when
you're looking at avid fans,
they are so vested
in their own set‐up
that I'm just
not convinced
that there's enough
customers out there
to make that
a very big market,
and for that reason,
I'm out.
Oh.
Ooh.
Matt, I think this would be
perfect for you.
We could take this to
the college‐football levels,
to NASCAR because
people love their tailgating,
as you know,
and when they have
a custom box
that's whatever football team
that you like,
that's a pride thing.
They live it.
John:
You know what?
You have the gift
and the curse
of I think what all of us have
up here as entrepreneurs.
When you first start out,
you want to be everything
to everybody,
and when you say,
"There's nothing else
out there on the market,"
that makes you want
to keep improving it.
I think you're gonna burn
a lot of capital
trying to keep improving it,
and that's where I'm scared.
So, I'm out.
♪♪
Higgins: To me, I think
you're actually just
here a little bit early.
I mean, if you had validated
a little bit deeper and ‐‐
Well, then,
there's still Mr. Wonderful ‐‐
There is Mr. Wonderful
and his very shark‐y deal.
...the only Shark
that believed in you.
We're gonna take it
to the end.
We just wanted some help
scaling, sourcing, marketing,
and figuring out
distribution plans.
You need cash.
So, we were hoping
that that's why
we would get a Shark today
that says,
"Okay, let's make this happen,"
and ‐‐
Are you saying no to my offer,
basically, in a nice way?
I am saying no to your offer
in a nice way.
Then there's nothing more
to do here.
♪♪
Respectively,
can I just say
we've worked our asses off
to get here,
every day,
working so hard, so...
So, just my dad and being here
with my brother,
I'm so lucky.
Mm.
Yeah.
Interpreter:
Yes, I agree.
We've been working so much
for so long towards this goal.
Just to be here today ‐‐
it feels like
we're champions already.
Taylor: Okay.
Okay.
Thanks for your time,
guys.
Congratulations, guys.
What a great experience.
Greiner: It's very cool.
You did a great job.
Good luck.
You guys
could have countered.
It doesn't hurt
to ask.
♪♪
Narrator:
Four Sharks are out.
The Johnson family
rejected Kevin's offer
of $250,000 as a line of credit
for 10% equity
and a royalty of $100 per
unit sold of Tailgate N Go.
You guys could have countered.
It doesn't hurt to ask.
♪♪
We would go $250,000
for 15%.
How do I get
my cash back?
Greiner:
And no royalty.
How do I get my cash back?
That's the question.
You're gonna get
your cash back...
How?
...as soon as we get
these boxes out.
We just tripled in sales
in the last six months, man.
O'Leary: It's a never‐ending
cost of capital as you grow.
I'm a Shark.
I've been doing this
for 10 years.
This business ‐‐ it will consume
millions of dollars.
It's not a horrible thing
if you can manage it,
but the thing
you won't have ‐‐
just so
we understand each other ‐‐
is you won't have me,
and I'm Mr. Wonderful.
And I can take this on social
to the moon.
They'll be setting these up
on the dark side of the moon
if I get involved.
[ Chuckles ]
O'Leary:
But that's my whole point.
Oh, my Lord.
Can we have one second?
Can we talk?
Go talk, yeah.
♪♪
You think you could sell this
on the dark side of the moon?
Yes.
♪♪
Matt?
I'm listening.
John: So, let me
get this straight ‐‐
let me get this straight ‐‐
everybody's out but Kevin,
but you're giving a counter
to Matt?
Okay, Matt, what do you think
about $250,000 at 20%?
♪♪
My concern is similar.
I don't want to wait
to get my cash back,
it's just sitting there,
hoping for an exit.
I'm not sure how big
the business is gonna be,
so I need a way
to get my capital back.
Would you consider,
like,
a small royalty or something
on each box?
Royalty?
Did I hear royalty?
[ Chuckles ]
To show you
I'm not greedy,
I will cut my royalty down
to $50 a unit,
which is very reasonable.
Your margins are okay.
Alright.
And then you have a deal
and you have a Shark
and I get behind it on social
and we blow it up.
But even
if I get behind it,
I'm gonna get you more orders
than you can fill.
See, now I feel like
I have to save you.
Here's what I'll do ‐‐
$250,000 straight equity
for 20%.
I'll say we'll do $50 royalty
until I get one‐X back,
and that's
my best offer.
How much equity
are you taking?
I'm taking 20%.
You greedy pig.
I can't believe ‐‐
I don't think
that is greedy.
It's outrageous.
I bring a ton
to it.
You're stealing
from this family.
No, I'm not.
I'm helping this family.
The theft,
it's abuse.
What were you doing?
I'm protecting this family
from you.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
♪♪
Matt...
Let's do your deal.
...let's do your deal!
Alright!
Cuban: Yeah!
Back out, back in,
back out, back in.
How you doing?
Thanks, buddy.
Good job.
You're doing great.
You guys did such a good job
with your pitch.
Taylor:
Thank you.
Alright.
How you doing?
Congrats, guys.
Thanks.
O'Leary: Now, Matt,
what's very important here
is now that you've learned
how to structure deals
from Mr. Wonderful, I will be
sending you an invoice.
♪♪
That was crazy.
That's awesome.
Interpreter: You just have to
move towards your goal
and just have to keep on going
until you reach your goal.
You know, we've been trying
for so long and then one day,
you can hit it and you can
really become a champ.
♪♪
Narrator: Last season,
we watched Justin Miller
and Tom Simon
make a deal with Alli Webb
for their cookie mix for dogs,
Zookies.
Webb:
I'm an investor at Healthy Spot,
which is an upscale boutique
for dogs and cats and animals,
and it's growing unbelievably.
So, I'm willing
to make you an offer.
You have a deal.
Narrator: Let's see
what they're up to now.
Miller:
Partnering with Alli
was hands‐down the best decision
we've ever made.
Zookies Cookies
is now found
in all 17 locations
of Healthy Spot
up and down
the coast of California.
Once Alli came on board,
the first thing that we tackled
was package design.
Our new branding
is night‐and‐day different.
‐Hi, guys.
‐Hey.
‐Hello.
How's it going?
Miller: Today, we're hosting
the Great Bark and Bake‐off,
a huge community event.
Alli helped
put this all together.
It's gonna be
an awesome day.
Webb: You guys,
this looks amazing.
It pops on shelves
really well, too.
Yeah.
It really pops
on shelves.
Webb:
I just love Tom and Justin
because they have
so much passion and energy.
The idea is different and new.
I just couldn't be more excited
to be a part of it.
You want a treat?
The event today
is all about brand awareness,
getting live feedback
from not only our customers,
but from our
furry friends, as well.
Hi, guys!
[ Laughter ]
When we pitched
on "Shark Tank,"
we had done about $40,000
in sales.
Simon: In the five months
since airing,
we have tripled our sales
to almost $124,000.
Alli has been an amazing
addition to the team.
She's really
rolled up her sleeves
and made some incredible
introductions for us.
We actually
wouldn't be here today
if it wasn't for Alli
and the deal that we made
on "Shark Tank."
Zookies! Zookies!
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a convenient solution
to a common modern problem.
♪♪
Hey, Sharks!
We're from Wilmington, Delaware,
and I'm Markevis Gideon.
I'm Jonathan Hoxter.
And I'm Jake Voorhees.
And we're here asking
for $150,000
in exchange for 20%
of our company.
[ Inhales sharply ]
All: And this is why we started
NERDiT Now.
Not a day goes by
that you don't hear about it.
Post‐Traumatic
Screen Disorder.
It's on the rise.
It's an epidemic.
And it's not like
once you break your device,
you can
fix it yourself.
Nope.
Companies don't want
to fix it for you.
They want you
to buy a new one.
But...
Together:
...we're the nerds.
And we can fix anything.
Here at NERDiT Now,
we purchase, repair,
and resell computers,
phones, and tablets.
See, what started
out of my two‐bedroom apartment
has now grown to two storefronts
and the Motherboard.
A mobile device
repair ambulance.
When you get hurt,
you call 911.
When your device gets hurt,
you call us.
And don't forget about
our remote kiosk,
where you can drop off
a broken device
and we'll fix it for you
in six hours.
Wait...same day?
Same day.
You don't even
have to talk to a human.
You see, Sharks, we're doing
everything to make this work.
I mean, I even took my wife
and my 4‐month‐old baby
and moved back in
with my in‐laws.
Typical millennial,
right?
I left my engineering career
behind for this.
And I put $20,000
on my credit card.
Man, we paid
that off already!
John: [ Laughs ]
It's been a long four‐year
journey to get to today, Sharks,
but we're ready
for the next chapter...
Together: ...with you!
So, whether you need
to fix a computer...
Or buy a tablet..
Or your kids simply want to play
baseball with your phone...
Together,
we can nerd this...
Or nerd that...
Here at...
Together:
...NERDiT Now.
[ Chuckles ]
Great job.
Whoo‐hoo.
I wish you guys
had more energy.
That's what you need.
Nice. Nice.
Well, tell us about the problem
that you're solving.
You said it's hard to figure out
where to go to.
Somebody charges me too much,
but I need to go to them?
What are you doing?
So, right now,
there's a huge amount
of problems that's going on.
Sometimes people don't trust
the people
that you're actually
going to...
Right.
...and a lot of times,
the price is just too high.
We offer free diagnostics,
and we make sure that you know
that we know what we're doing.
All of the work that we do
is covered by our insurance.
I have a lot of experience
in this area
because I have
an 18‐year‐old daughter
who constantly
breaks her screen.
Yeah.
And we end up
going to the mall ‐‐
those little kiosks ‐‐
and spend about 150 bucks
to do it.
So, are you improving upon
that service?
Yes.
So,
what do you charge?
So, right now,
if you go to a kiosk,
generally, they charge about
$130 for an iPhone 7 repair.
We charge $90
for that same repair...
That's good.
Wow.
...and it comes with
a six‐month warranty,
and we do all of the repairs
in front of you.
The ambulance
comes to the person?
It can.
It can?
We have
a brick‐and‐mortar store, too.
How many of these
vending machines do you have?
So, currently, this is a
prototype that we just created.
Okay.
We came up with this idea
about three months ago,
and we're working on a software
right now.
So, right now,
we have a storefront,
we have a mobile store,
which is this ambulance,
but we can't have the ambulance
in multiple locations.
So, we see maybe eight repairs
in a two‐hour period.
So, this kiosk
plus ambulance model
actually allows us
to scale that.
One ambulance can service
as many as 10 kiosks.
Higgins: Is it
a huge national business?
It's basically like the Uber
for screen repair,
where they have
independent contractors?
So, there is no national brand.
That's actually the opportunity.
No one has created
a national brand
where they actually
trust it.
They have
these mall kiosks.
Sure,
you have Geek Squad,
but they want to be a service
provider for everything.
They'll do
your home appliance,
they'll do whatever.
So, they don't have
a niche market
that they're actually isolating
device repair.
That's what
we're gonna do.
Tell me how many people
are going to feel okay about
putting their laptop
or their iPad or whatever,
their phone
into this refrigerator
and just
leaving it there.
So,
what we plan on doing
is actually starting testing
markets with the Motherboard.
The Motherboard?
The Motherboard
is our ambulance.
The Motherboard actually
tests the market first.
We go there and build the trust
within the organization
that we're partnering with
as the host organization,
and once people start feeling
as if they can trust us,
we then place
a kiosk there.
That's tough, guys.
What was your history
before this?
Myself,
at 12 years old,
a teacher gave me
a computer,
and when he gave me that
computer, it changed my life.
I end up going to a high school
where I became
a Microsoft‐certified systems
engineer by 17 years old.
Wow.
I then went off to college,
graduated with my degrees,
then went to China for
five years, where I started...
Cuban: [ Chuckles ]
...working for
an import‐export company.
I opened up a bar
while I was running ‐‐
In China?
In China.
You speak Chinese?
Um...
[ Speaks Chinese ]
Oh [speaks Chinese]
Oh.
[ Laughs ]
Well, can I just tell you ‐‐
I'm a Microsoft‐certified
systems engineer.
Hey!
And I also
opened up a bar, so...
We're there.
[ Chuckles ]
What are the other
two guys' histories?
So, my history is born
and raised in Delaware,
graduated from
the University of Delaware.
What was your degree?
Finance.
Yeah, I knew you were
the financial guy.
I also went to
the University of Delaware.
I have
a civil engineering degree.
I left the engineering industry
behind a few years ago.
What do you want to do
with the $150,000?
So, with the $150,000,
what we plan on doing
is buying two more Motherboards
so that
we can test the markets
both in Philadelphia
and Baltimore,
want to buy 10 kiosks,
as well as finish the
development of the software.
So, when you figure out where
you put the Motherboards, right,
how does that
all work out?
And then you send out an alert
telling people,
"This is where
we're gonna be today"?
We join
other food‐truck circuits.
Smart.
So, where the food trucks go,
we go.
That's how we got into
a lot of organizations.
Oh, that's interesting.
That's interesting.
What are your sales?
I don't think we heard.
Year to date,
$74,000.
Sale forecasted this year
to make about $250,000.
What did you do
last year?
Last year was $157,000.
I just want
to try to help you out
'cause I don't feel like
you've done a good enough job
explaining the potential
of a Motherboard.
How much revenue
can one do?
Generally,
for the ambulance right now,
when we do a 5‐day period,
it's about $30,000 a month.
That's good
if you can do it.
Hey, guys, look,
this is a great business
for you guys, right?
I've been there.
But it's still driven
by proximity.
You got to go
where the people are at,
and it's driven
by your time.
You have to have somebody
physically doing that work,
so it's hard to scale.
I've been there.
And so, while it's
a great business for you guys
'cause you can just grind it
and go and grow it
and make more and more money
that goes into your pocket,
it's not
really investable.
So, for those reasons,
I'm out.
Thank you.
You know, I think
that if you were, like,
in a Kinko's,
in a FedEx,
in locations where you just
need to be in people's faces,
and then to me,
the marketing angle is,
"We will fix your phone screen
in 20 minutes."
It's like
pull up and go, right?
If you can be in enough places
where people can see that,
of course
I'd go to you.
It's easy.
Love your story,
think it's amazing.
You're brilliant,
so you'll go far.
But you're at
an early stage,
and I don't think
I'm the right partner.
I'm out.
Thank you, Lori.
O'Leary: Guys, I don't think
this is investable.
I really don't.
I think there's nothing wrong
with the business for you guys.
I wanted to see a big
roll‐out strategy on trucks
that had a really high return,
and I didn't get that.
So, I'm sorry,
I'm out.
Thank you.
I have a way that we're gonna
scale this company,
and if you don't believe
in anything else,
you best believe in us.
We're taking this
to the moon.
We're not asking for you guys
to work for us,
and we don't necessarily
want to work for you.
We want the money
to work for everybody
so that we can take you
to the moon.
You're our astronauts, Sharks.
This is our everything.
We're gonna take this
to the moon.
Listen, guys,
I just don't personally think
that you should take
an investment in it,
to be very honest.
I love that
when I'm sleeping,
the register's still ringing,
you know?
FUBU is still selling
at any minute of the day.
I don't have to
physically hire other people
and do things like that,
so I just don't think
it's investable.
So I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you.
Thanks, Daymond.
Who's left?
Matt?
Yep.
You have invented
this very clever,
well‐branded truck
and are able
to put it somewhere
with no occupancy cost,
and you're able
to generate enough volume
that you can charge and undercut
your competition.
That's a brilliant idea.
My advice to you ‐‐
continue to scale that.
Save up the money to go ahead
and buy a second truck.
It's a smart model.
There's an endless need
to replace screens,
so you're
onto something.
I just think you're here
a little bit too early.
So, for that reason,
I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you, Sharks.
Cuban:
You know what?
You didn't get a deal, but just
go out and prove us wrong.
Higgins: Alright,
good luck.
Bye.
Good luck, guys.
♪♪
The Chinese say jixu,
which means "keep going."
Jixu, jixu, jixu.
We're gonna
keep on going.
John:
Why take in the money
to then give away
20 to 30 more percent
of all what you've worked
so hard for?
They can just
build it slowly.
Cuban: It's gonna take them
a year to save up the money
to buy
another one of those things,
and he just wanted
to shortcut it.
Nothing wrong with that.
It's just not really investable.
Kev, give me two scoops
with some sprinkles, please.
Vanilla or strawberry?
[ Chuckles ]
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a stylish
and affordable way
to kick it on the golf course.
♪♪
[ Chuckles ]
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Tyler Stuart.
And I'm John Krosky.
And we're seeking
$300,000
for 8% of our company,
Golfkicks.
The problem we tackle
is that people are just tired
of golf shoes.
They're ugly,
uncomfortable, expensive.
So, why play golf
in your grandpa's shoes?
Wouldn't it be cool
if you could roll up
to the course
and pull out your favorite pair
of high‐tops?
That's why
we created Golfkicks.
We turned
ordinary sneakers
into
extraordinary golf shoes.
Greiner: Wow.
We've had people put Golfkicks
in thousand‐dollar sneakers,
flip‐flops,
and even cowboy boots.
Let me show you
how this works.
He's grabbed
his favorite pair of kicks,
mapped out the traction
on the bottom,
take your handy
Golfkicks traction kit.
We've already cheated
and put some in.
Screw in the cleat,
and boom,
you've got golf shoes.
We just sold out
of version one,
and we need
your help to grow.
And we got product
for you guys.
But we've got some gear
for you.
Got some gear.
We got FUBU's for you.
John: I saw that.
I think those sneakers
are amazing.
We got
some fun hats,
and we made you all
a pair of kicks.
Here, these are yours
right here, Matt.
Okay.
Thank you.
And one of our kits
is in there.
There you go.
Thank you.
These are ‐‐
Daymond and Mark.
Cuban: Appreciate it.
Thank you.
Greiner: Okay.
I'm a golfer.
Oh, nice.
I think
this is very interesting.
Do I have to drill a hole
into the sole?
So, version one,
which we just sold out of,
we recommend
doing a pilot hole.
You want at least a third
of an inch of a sole thickness,
and you need rubber.
What do you recommend using
to create a pilot hole?
Just anything?
So, we include that
in the kit,
and we actually have
a version coming
that does not even require
a pilot hole.
Are you solving
the problem
of people not wanting
to buy special shoes for golf
or because you want
more style choice?
They want to look cool while
they're out there golfing.
It's the cool factor,
for sure, Mark.
Is there any restriction
on the golf course?
You know, like, you're not
supposed to wear certain things?
There's not.
We've had a few people
comment, right, that,
"They would never allow Vans
at my country club."
Yeah, back in the day, right?
Yeah.
'Cause it's a little bit
punk‐rock,
but we think that's part of
the same reason people love it.
O'Leary:
Let's go to distribution
'cause I've looked at many
golf deals over the years,
and it's a very tricky
distribution system
to get to the, you know ‐‐
the pro shops.
That's exactly right.
So, our plan right now ‐‐
and we just got started.
We've only had product
for three months.
We sell direct
on our website.
Some of the next moves
will be Amazon
and get kind of an anchor,
big‐box golf retailer,
but we know eventually, it would
be nice to get into the ‐‐
You know
what's extremely scary?
You're just
getting started
and your valuation is
a little over $3 million.
$3.7 million.
So, talk to me.
So, in the last
three months
that we've just started
selling product,
we've already done
$120,000.
Oh!
That makes sense!
[ Laughter ]
A cool $5 million.
Sorry for asking.
[ Laughter ]
Stuart: No, no.
It's alright.
Like Krosky said,
we've done $120,000,
we sold out
really quickly.
We'll do a million dollars
year one with product.
Greiner: Wait, wait. What are
you basing that off of?
How do you know that?
Stuart: We would have to
seriously fumble not to.
Higgins: Yeah.
You're saying you're gonna do
a million this year?
We're gonna do a million dollars
this year.
What does
the kit sell for?
$29. $29.
That's cool. And what does
it cost you to make?
Five bucks.
That's even better.
Is anybody
knocking you off already?
Both: No.
Do you have a patent
on anything?
We do.
So, we filed
the provisional 2018.
We just did our non‐provisional
May 8, 2019.
So, nobody else
has a patent out there
where you're anchoring a cleat
into a shoe yourself?
That's right.
We have good mojo
on the patent side so far.
I got another question.
Why does anybody play golf?
'Cause I hate it.
Because of those.
Greiner:
I love it.
I would second that.
I hate it.
Stuart: We know
you're not into golf, Mark.
Yeah, if somebody could answer
that question.
Greiner:
It's so relaxing.
You're out with nature.
It's calming.
So is fishing, but you
get something to eat
at the end of the day.
Hey, guys,
you know what?
Here's my general thought
about it.
You want a partner
who obviously is passionate
about that stuff.
I don't relate to this business
at all.
I'm out.
Alright.
Higgins:
I agree with Daymond.
I think if you're gonna invest
in something,
you should at least
have some interest at all.
I have zero interest in golf.
I've played twice in my life.
I wouldn't be a good
partner for you, so for
that reason, I'm out.
Thanks, Matt.
Thanks.
Cool idea, though.
There is crossover
into other sports, too.
What other sports
is there crossover into?
Well, the future version
that we've been working on ‐‐
it can take a pivot.
It can take a high‐speed
starting and stopping.
So, it'll help you get into
soccer, et cetera.
Soccer or, like, kids,
for example.
Have you ever noticed
how fast kids' shoes wear out?
Or they outgrow them,
right?
O'Leary:
Okay. I'm a golfer.
I'm looking at it saying,
"I wish it wasn't 300K,"
'cause it's a product.
It's not really
a company yet.
I mean, the golf‐shoe market's
an $8 1/2 billion market.
Look, I'm not saying it's bad.
It's interesting.
But the way you structured
the deal makes it hard
for me to maneuver.
So, for that reason,
I'm out.
Alright.
Cuban: What do you guys
need specifically?
The mentorship
is a huge part of it.
Some advisers
as we go into Amazon,
as we go into retail.
Listen, you're brand‐new.
You're just starting, alright?
You don't even have down
the final iteration,
which I would think
you have that coming any day.
I'm gonna give you
an offer
based on how much risk
I think there is here.
I'll give you the $300,000
as a loan at 8% interest,
but I want a royalty
of a dollar per.
I will stop the royalty
once I get paid back,
and I'll take
5% of the company.
Okay.
Appreciate that.
Lori, why you going so low
on the royalty?
You see their margins?
♪♪
Alright, back to me.
[ Laughter ]
The royalty's ridiculous,
right?
When you have
that much margin ‐‐
yeah, it's easy for us
to think, "Pay us a royalty,"
but you're gonna do
distributions.
If business is good,
there's gonna be
so much cash flow.
You'll do distributions, which
are better than royalties.
So, again,
what's the one thing you need
just to make
this thing take off?
'Cause it's not
really cash, right?
Stuart:
The cash is helpful
because we're transitioning
to a metal screw in the part.
It's a little different
manufacturing process.
There's gonna be
some setup on that.
Call that $100,000.
The inventory is gonna
start going a lot faster.
That's the key.
Okay.
So, as we were sitting here,
I gave you my offer,
but Mark started
asking questions,
which he has
every right to do,
but my fellow Shark
sitting next to me said,
"You're crazy
with the dollar royalty."
So, our deal
is getting worse?
Back to me, guys.
It's getting worse.
So I will tell you,
while you sit and wait,
while I love you
and I'm one with the golf ‐‐
Well, that's what happens
when you're not decisive.
It's gonna get worse.
I'm one with the golf,
but now I'm going to $2 per.
♪♪
Stuart: In your network,
which we know is awesome,
how do you see it
taking place?
I see this
as targeting golfers.
See how smart she is?
I think it's Instagram ads
all the way.
People need to see this
to get it.
I don't see this
going to retail.
You're gonna make much
more money by selling direct.
Are you doing anything,
Mark?
Yeah. I'm trying not
to be rude and interrupt.
Okay, let him get
his offer out, Lori.
Go ahead, Mark.
Guys,
I'll make you an offer.
$300,000 for 15%.
No royalties.
Once you get into
the kids' sports,
that's where
I think your grand slam is.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
The kids' thing's huge.
That's my offer.
You guys can say yes or no.
♪♪
Would you do 12%,
Mark?
♪♪
I'll do 13%.
13%. Done.
Let's do it.
Done.
Let's go.
[ Applause ]
Alright.
Greiner: Congrats.
Thank you, Lori.
Hey.
Congrats.
It's a good idea.
Let's make some money.
It's gonna be a lot of fun.
Awesome.
I might even
get back on the course.
This is a fun one.
We'll get you out there.
Awesome.
Cuban:
Thanks, guys.
Alright.
Thanks, everyone.
See ya.
♪♪
To get Cuban in at this point
to ratchet things up,
it's gonna be great.
O'Leary: Let me show you
how it's done.
Can we get a bet going
on this?
Okay.
Observe how it's done.
♪♪
[ Cheering ]
[ Applause ]
There you go!
Whoo‐whoo!
Good man.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a remedy for aches and pains.
♪♪
Hey, Sharks.
My name
is Shaquille Walker,
and I'm the world 800‐meter
world record holder.
I'm Jared Ward, 2016 Olympic
marathon runner for Team USA.
And I'm Jono DiPeri,
and I'm...
an engineer.
[ Laughter ]
I'm also the founder and CEO
of our company, MyoStorm,
and we are based
in Provo, Utah.
Sharks, when was the last time
one of you woke up in pain,
with a sore back,
a kink in your neck,
or any other sore spots?
Don't worry.
We'll fix you up in a second.
Well, actually,
it will take several seconds,
but it will be quick,
and believe it or not,
we have all felt pain
and experienced sore muscles.
100 million Americans
report having
chronic neck or back pain
in the U. S. alone.
$600 billion are spent annually
managing pain just like this.
As a professional athlete,
I experience pain every day.
I blew thousands of dollars
on recovery equipment,
but nothing produced
the results I needed.
I felt the same way as Shaq.
We both knew...
Together:
...there had to be a better way.
And that's why
we invented the Meteor.
The Meteor is
a patent‐pending,
FDA‐compliant
medical massage device
that utilizes
cutting‐edge technology
in vibration
and heat therapy
to help reduce pain
and speed up muscular recovery.
The Meteor's versatile
and easy to use.
Just use like
any traditional roller,
combining the benefits
of pressure from rolling out
with the Meteor's addition
of heat and vibration.
You can use it
while lying down
or sitting in a chair
or just holding it and applying
pressure wherever it's sore.
The Meteor was designed with
professional athletes in mind...
But it can be used by
and benefit everyone
who experiences pain.
So, Sharks, whether you just
finished running 26.2 miles...
Are recovering
from an injury...
Or just slept weird...
...the Meteor
can benefit you.
We are seeking $150,000
for 10% of our company.
So, Sharks...
Together:
Who's ready to roll with us?
Greiner:
Can we get samples?
Yeah.
Good news ‐‐
we brought gifts for you.
Cool.
Oh, good.
Here you go.
Awesome.
Red for you.
I'll go black.
Yep, take a box.
Go ahead and take the box.
Greiner: Ooh.
DiPeri:
These ones are warmed up.
Ooh.
O'Leary:
They're warm.
Thank you.
Thank you, sir.
First of all,
we pick it up and it is warm.
Wow.
This thing is hot.
I like the heat.
Walker: Your Meteors
are already on and heated.
If I'm in bed, I'll just put it
on my neck and relax on it,
turn on the heat.
Like that,
Matt.
Yeah.
There you go.
Matt's got it figured out.
Thank you.
It's really cool.
I got to give you credit.
The design's good.
Thank you.
You got fire.
Tells you it's heat.
It's smart,
so it's global.
Thank you, thank you.
So, did you get
the vibration?
Yeah.
How's it feeling,
Mr. Wonderful?
Fantastic.
I use a roller.
Okay.
I hate the pain,
but it's the gain I go after.
[ Laughs ]
So, one of the things
you'll notice ‐‐
what's nice about rolling
with this is the vibration
is designed to help mask
a little bit of the pain.
So, it's actually
more comfortable
than just using
a traditional roller.
Mark,
do you feel the heat?
Oh, yeah.
[ Groans ]
Ward:
Says it all.
[ Groans ]
Says it all
right there.
He's not afraid
to get in there.
Oh, hell no.
I'm an old pro.
[ Laughs ]
Yep. Yep.
That's pretty cool.
That's nice.
Greiner: Okay.
There's other balls out there.
So, what differentiates you is
the heat and vibrating aspects?
DiPeri: Correct.
My background ‐‐ I was a
mechanical engineering student,
and in my research,
I studied how vibration
affects the human body.
We've learned that there's
really specific frequencies
and amplitudes that are
more therapeutic to the body,
and we've just tried
to optimize it
and add
the addition of heat.
Kind of some background.
We started with
a Kickstarter last September.
We made a small production,
around a thousand units
to fulfill
the Kickstarter backers
and learn if there was anything
we needed to change,
any tweaks, get feedback
from a lot of our athletes.
What was your goal
on Kickstarter and how'd you do?
So, our goal was $20,000.
We did about $70,000.
Wow.
What do you guys
sell these for,
and what does it cost you
to make?
We've tested
between $130 and $175.
We're gonna be
selling them $160.
♪♪
That's expensive.
Wow.
John: Yeah.
Yeah, but when you look into
the space,
there's a lot of competitors
that are selling
inferior products,
less features.
That are heated
and vibrate?
That don't heat.
What's it cost you
to make?
$40 landed.
So, some of these products
cost $600,
and then at the lower end,
obviously,
you have
your $15 foam roller,
but this really is
a superior product
at a more affordable
price range,
and, I mean,
consider how much you paid
for your last massage.
Guys, I'm gonna just
tell you the biggest
differentiator, right?
When you have a roller,
vibrating or otherwise,
you got to get
on the floor, right?
Yeah.
Or against a wall.
And that just limits,
whereas here,
you know,
laying on bed,
you don't need to have
a hard surface underneath
this like you do
with the roller.
Exactly.
Higgins: So, once again, how
many units have you sold?
So, we've sold total
about 900 units.
So,
what are total sales?
Greiner: So, what are
your total sales?
So, total sales,
with the Kickstarter,
is about $120,000.
♪♪
That's not a lot.
I feel the $160 price point
is a problem.
That's tough, yeah.
Because if your cost
is $40 landed, right,
why are you putting
so much mark‐up on it?
Because they can.
Yeah, to that.
Yeah, but that's never
the right thing to do.
I disagree.
So, we have tested it
with the small‐market dollars
we've been using.
We've been running tests
and see how the market responds.
Have you tested this
at $99?
We haven't.
Or was it always
over a hundred?
No, here's why
that's wrong. Lori ‐‐
Alright, here's one thing
that I would gather for sure.
If it was
under a hundred dollars,
you'd do better.
No.
It is always ‐‐ No.
Mark,
don't even go there.
Nope.
There is always
a price‐point freezing
at $50
and at a hundred.
Yeah. Yeah.
And when you are under $50,
you sell way better,
and when you're under a hundred,
and that is proven time
and again.
The goal
is to maximize profit.
Lori, if they go 50% margin
and they go to retail,
then it will be $160.
Is your plan
to go to retail?
Higgins: By the way,
do you have a vision?
You're gonna go
direct‐to‐consumer
as long as possible?
Or do you want
to go to retail?
So, the plan was
to stay direct‐to‐consumer.
We are interested
in retail.
We'd probably start
with specialty, you know?
Here's why it works
at a higher price.
And $169's relatively high,
higher than I expected,
because the people
who get this off the bat
are already using
other options, right?
They're already educated and
they see the perceived value.
Yeah.
But because
it's an electronics good
and because
you're an engineer,
you're gonna continue
to optimize it.
You might make it a little
bit smaller because it
fits in little places,
you'll push the cost down,
right?
And once you get the cost
down to $20,
then you can come out
with a $99 version.
With scaling, we already expect
it to come down dramatically.
How far
can you get the price?
So, right now,
with our current manufacturers,
they said they can get it down
to $27.
At what volumes?
10,000.
At 10,000.
Which would then
allow you, then,
to be under a hundred,
for sure.
That's a lot of volume.
Guys,
I love the product.
I'm tired of wasting time
with all these guys, right?
Well, wait, Mark,
I was about to make an offer.
That's why.
I'm the only
fine‐tuned athlete up here.
Listen, guys,
here's what I'll do ‐‐
I'll give you 250K
for 20%, right?
So, that gives you
the capital you need.
Obviously,
I can help you get it out there,
but if you want to hear
all the options, I don't
want to waste my time.
O'Leary: You should listen
to other options.
I'll just take a nap.
You guys let me know.
If you want me in
for $250,000 for 20% ‐‐
You're letting him bully you
like that.
Don't get bullied
by Mark.
Just let me know and
if not, I'll let you
play with the masses.
Higgins: Mark, Mark, Mark.
Just let him bully you, huh?
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in,
and Mark has an offer
on the table
for the heated, vibrating
massage‐ball company MyoStorm.
If you want to hear
all the options, I don't
want to waste my time.
You should listen
to other options.
I'll just take a nap.
You guys let me know.
If you want me in
for $250,000 for 20% ‐‐
Greiner:
He's given you a clock.
You're letting him bully you
like that.
O'Leary: Don't get bullied
by Mark.
If not, I'll let you
play with the masses.
Mark, Mark, Mark.
Would you want to partner up?
No.
O'Leary: I would like
to make an offer.
No, 'cause I can
get them in anywhere.
John: We got another offer
over here, guys.
I'd like to make
an offer.
Hey, we got
another offer over here, man.
Mark, we love the
offer. We would like
to hear Kevin's offer.
Okay, I'm out.
I'm out.
♪♪
I like it.
I'll make you an offer.
I'm gonna give you the $150,000
for 5% equity,
half of what you thought
you had to give away.
But I want a buck a ball
until I get $500,000 back,
then that royalty
goes away.
That's a good deal
for you guys.
♪♪
I'm interested, as well.
I think it's a great product,
and I don't think
there's anything like it.
I do have
the ability to reach
that same sports demographic
through my role, you know,
at the Miami Dolphins
or huge soccer tournament.
Right. Right.
Can reach anybody.
Your 16,000 Instagram followers
are gonna be excited.
O'Leary:
Let him get his offer out.
Oh!
[ Laughs ]
I love it!
I love it. We're bragging about
Instagram followers.
Wait. I got to pause for that.
Alright, so, moving on.
I'm willing to give you,
you know, $150,000 for 10%.
Greiner: That's what
they came in asking for.
Yep.
Thanks.
I've given you
your offer.
That's all
very interesting.
However, why give up
that much equity?
That's crazy.
We love the offer.
I will get back to you
in one second.
O'Leary: Alright.
I want
to understand something.
Yes?
Do you have goals,
and do you aspire
and can you...
Oh, Lori,
we're negotiating.
...get to under
a hundred dollars?
What are you moaning about?
Why are you always moaning?
'Cause it's not relevant.
It's not relevant, Lori.
You're not
a fine‐tuned athlete.
It's not relevant.
It is relevant.
We're negotiating.
Alright,
I'm getting tired.
Please, no more kumbaya, Lori.
Enough, already.
Go away, go away.
He's just threatened.
He's threatened
'cause I'm still interested.
No, these guys
have no motivation
and they're lackluster.
I'll give you
the same offer as Kevin.
♪♪
We're gonna talk about it
right here,
just amongst ourselves
for a sec.
What was Kevin's offer?
A buck a ball...
O'Leary: Buck a ball
till I get $500,000 back,
and I get 5%.
And you get 5%.
Yeah.
I like that.
And they get
a fine‐tuned athlete.
That's the thing.
♪♪
[ Indistinct whispering ]
Yep. Okay. Alright.
Well?
We got an answer.
Mr. Wonderful and Matt,
we love your offers.
♪♪
But...
Lori,
you've got a deal.
Ha!
Higgins: Oh!
What happened?
[ Laughter ]
They wanted QVC,
I guess.
John: What the hell?
What happened?
Guys, guys.
Why did you...
Guys, high five.
It was
the same exact deal.
I was about
to make you an offer.
There's value, we think,
in some of the ideas that
she has about lowering cost.
That's something that ‐‐
Hey, what if we do sell
double or triple the units,
and that's something we can work
on ‐‐ getting our costs down.
Okay, roll your asses
out of here.
Guys,
I'm really disappointed.
Yeah, I want to throw the ball
at you now!
[ Laughs ]
Greiner: Good choice,
gentlemen.
Thanks.
I will not
let you down.
[ Exhales sharply ]
Alright, man.
[ Laughs ]
DiPeri:
We really didn't come in
expecting to get so many offers
from the Sharks.
And it was a really difficult
decision to make,
but we feel amazing.
It really makes you believe in
what you're doing.
It makes it seem
all so worth it.
I don't know
what just happened.
Whoo!
Girl power.
♪♪